[Musica]
[Applauso]
che cos'è la fiducia
ve lo siete mai chiesto
eppure è un tratto fondamentale della
nostra quotidianità
delle nostre relazioni
nel nostro lavoro della nostra vita
familiare
è direttamente correlata alla nostra
felicità
riuscite a immaginare una relazione che
funziona senza fiducia
come sarebbe il nostro mondo se non
potessimo fidarci di nessuno
non potersi fidare di un collega di un
socio di un amico
non potersi fidare di un fratello di un
genitore di un figlio
di nessuno
io l'ho imparato sulla mia pelle da
piccola
quant'è importante la fiducia a 13 anni
sui banchi della terza media
ho sentito una conversazione la
professoressa stava dicendo mia madre ma
andate a lavorare
sono soldi sprecati farla studiare
ancora
in quel momento il mio piccolo mondo sia
incrinato
in quel momento ho capito che lei non
credeva in me
pochi anni dopo stavo collezionando
letteralmente collezionando
riconoscimenti e borse di studio con la
promessa di cominciare a lavorare subito
aveva convinto mia mamma a farmi provare
un istituto è un istituto professionale
la scuola alberghiera
con il lavoro ho riscattato la mia
libertà
la libertà
di crescere la libertà di scoprire cose
nuove
sei borse di studio mentre lavoravo la
migliore della scuola la cosiddetta
secchiona la miglia tra le migliori del
mio corso universitario
e poi è successo di nuovo
lo stesso maledetto problema
non si fidavano di me
ero la persona più titolata nella stanza
ma al lavoro non mi ascoltavano perché
questa domanda mi stava ossessionando
sin da quando ero piccola
e pensare che durante l'università ho
fatto un sacco di ricerche sulla fiducia
la fiducia nei mercati finanziari come
cambiano i comportamenti delle persone
quando sono diffidenti nella mia tesi ho
sviluppato ben tre aspetti della fiducia
tre aspetti chiave il primo quello che
oggi un po famoso come network analysis
cioè analisi dei dati aggregati era
emerso proprio che il comportamento
delle persone la vicinanza tra le
persone cambia quando c'è più confidenza
il secondo aspetto basato su una ricerca
scientifica sul cervello umano aveva
fatto ha fatto emergere che l'uomo può
fidarsi degli estranei
noi ci fidiamo degli estranei
quando assomigliano a qualcuno che non
ha mai tradito le nostre aspettative
il terzo aspetto
derivante da un esperimento sociologico
aveva dimostrato e mi aveva appassionato
perché dimostrava la relazione tra
fiducia e tempo la fiducia aumenta
all'aumentare del tempo le persone sono
più disposte a perdonare errori in buona
fede quando la relazione profonda non
quando è all'inizio
nonostante tutte le mie ricerche
nonostante tutta la mia passione su
questo tema
succedeva ancora
non si fidavano di ma
perché
qual era il pezzo del puzzle che mancava
perché non mi ascoltavano
da loro ha continuato a cercare
e in tutto questo tempo e in oltre
20.000 appuntamenti perché sono anche
cresciuti
che cosa ho capito
oggi sono qui proprio per condividerli
la mia esperienza quello che ho scoperto
ma per aiutarvi a
cominciare sin da domani a sperimentare
le cose che vedremo oggi per ridurre la
vostra frustrazione da relazioni
interrotte per evitare di sprecare tempo
in relazioni che non hanno solide radici
per diventare più efficaci anche a
livello professionale
saliremo insieme su una scala quella che
io chiamo la scala della fiducia
faremo cinque gradini
e il primo si chiama visibilità
da qui tutto parte in una relazione
siamo in due
non è possibile iniziare una relazione
se reciprocamente non sappiamo chi siamo
cosa facciamo
e quali sono i nostri obiettivi
vi fidereste di dare il vostro
portafoglio a qualcuno che avete appena
conosciuto
in questo momento la risposta
e li avete appena seminato nel terreno
non esiste ancora la relazione non vi fa
sentire abbastanza tranquilli
il secondo scalino e quello dell'empatia
l'empatia è quel momento in cui si
comincia ad andare oltre che siamo e
cosa facciamo
e cominciamo a mettere le nostre
vulnerabilità sul piatto a sentire
qualcosa a livello emotivo che ci
consente di parlare del nostro perché
facciamo le cose
è un momento è uno stadio della
relazione
ma vi sentireste tranquilli a dare il
vostro portafogli a una persona
condividete dei bei momenti
l'empatia è condizione necessaria ma non
sufficiente per sviluppare una relazione
che rendesse vi rende sereni in quel
gesto
qui il seme comincia a radicare
ed è debole è una relazione ancora
debole
il terzo scalino la confidenza
è un momento estremamente importante
qui c'è il giro di vite di una relazione
nella confidenza c'è ascolto reciproco
c'è ascolto aperto
si comincia a parlare dei propri
progetti
si cominciano a buttare giù i muri della
diffidenza si comincia a diventare veri
le prime informazioni vere non quelle
che diciamo a tutti
ma vi sentireste tranquilli a dare il
vostro portafoglio a una persona con cui
vi piace confrontarvi ogni tanto
la confidenza uno stadio molto
importante ma anche qui la condizione è
necessaria per sviluppare una relazione
ma non è sufficiente non mi fa sentire
tranquilli per fare quel gesto
le radici stanno crescendo la piantina
sta emergendo
ma è ancora da proteggere
il gradino della credibilità il quarto è
un gradino molto particolare molto
speciale
e gradino in cui si fa progetti insieme
si cominciano a condividere momenti
anche personali familiari
molto intensamente c'è tanta relazione
c'è tanto confronto
e iniziano le prove e inizia si inizia a
raccogliere i segni dell'affidabilità
reciproca
e qui la piantina comincia a diventare
pianta è ben più radicata e va protetta
sulla della rete in peste
sareste disponibili a dare il vostro
portafoglio a una persona con cui avete
una rivelazione
già così solida
qui nasce il dubbio
e la domanda diventa
nella vostra testa probabilmente quanti
soldi ci sono
perché è un parametro relativo
quindi nel momento in cui questa domanda
me la faccio e la relazione è quasi
oltre la credibilità probabilmente
glielo date completamente il portafoglio
a priori dalla dalla cifra
se appena
svaligiata la confidenza entrati in
credibilità magari per una cifra piccola
di rodate piccola per voi ea si intende
il quinto gradino l'autorevolezza lo
stadio massimo di relazione
e quella quello stadio in cui non c'è
solamente ascolto attivo reciproco non
c'è una grande frequenza di relazione
c'è un sostegno un supporto costante le
prove della della relazione le prove
dell'affidabilità sono quotidiane
e in quel momento in cui se vi faccio la
domanda saresti in grado di dare il
vostro portafoglio a una persona che vi
fa sentire con le spalle protette che
c'è sempre nel momento di bisogno che
c'è sempre nel momento dello stimolo
la risposta è sì perché mi fa sentire
sicuro
questo è lo stadio dove la piantina è
diventata albero e sta dando buoni
frutti
e in cui è importante che io vi ricordo
che la relazione in autorevolezza come
in tutti gli altri stati deve essere
reciproca quindi ad essere un sentimento
reciproco
trovate entrambi
perché nelle relazioni si tende a
dimenticare che siamo in due
possiamo fare una colpa la professoressa
di italiano perché non ha visto in me
del potenziale
le avevo veramente fatto vedere il mio
potenziale
no
con lei ero sempre chiusa introversa
era la professoressa di una materia che
detestava
che cosa serve allora per creare
fiducia
conoscere noi stessi
mettersi a disposizione dell'altro farci
vedere dare le prove del nostro
potenziale
e attendere
ma soprattutto
conoscere le esperienze dell'altra
persona capire quali sono gli elementi
su cui giudicherà un'altra persona quali
sono le esperienze negative che ha avuto
fino a quel momento è riuscire a
interpretare quali saranno i tempi con
cui l'altra persona maturerà fiducia
verso di noi
i quali sono le prove che ha bisogno di
vedere per fidarsi di noi
che cos'è la fiducia allora
dal latino si dice sempre fiducia e
possiamo
semplificarlo in un concetto per cui è
quel senso di tranquillità e di serenità
e sicurezza che ci ispira qualcosa o
qualcuno
quindi il mio suggerimento di cuore per
voi oggi
ispirate fiducia nelle persone che avete
intorno
aiutatele a sentirsi sicuri ti vuoi
[Applauso]
[Musica]